los líderes del g7 y representantes de
la Unión Europea están en Japón en la
agenda aparecen los asuntos globales más
desafiantes que deben afrontarse en este
momento
el mundo ahora enfrentan múltiples
crisis como la crisis climática la
pandemia y la invasión rusa de Ucrania
el g7 que debe responder de manera
efectiva los problemas importantes que
enfrenta la comunidad internacional en
el centro de la escena el conflicto en
el este de Europa al mismo tiempo que
reafirmaron el apoyo a Ucrania volvieron
a ampliar las sanciones contra Rusia
para limitar ingresos comerciales de
metales y diamantes restringidos
exportaciones de maquinaria Industrial
herramientas y tecnologías y castigos a
200 entidades que ayudan a su producción
y capacidad energética esto mientras
espera la intervención de bolodimir
selensky durante el fin de semana
Allí se decidirán cosas muy importantes
y por lo tanto la presencia de nuestro
presidente es absolutamente esencial
para defender nuestros intereses
otro punto álgido fue el poderío
económico de China ausente en esta
Cumbre el g7 Busca métodos para
fortalecer la cooperación entre ellos
sin atentar contra el desarrollo de la
segunda economía más grande del mundo en
tanto instaron a beijina desacelerar el
desarrollo nuclear precisamente desde
Hiroshima donde la detonación de una
bomba nuclear estadounidense usó el
punto final a la Segunda Guerra Mundial
en 1945